los últimos reportes de la devesa
sugieren que aunque omicron es más
contagiosa es menos severa que otras
variantes como la delta por ejemplo esto
es un parte de tranquilidad para el
mundo
no yo creo que no debemos estar con una
actitud de tranquilidad es lo que
debemos estar alertas la situación que
estamos viviendo en estos momentos en el
mundo entero y en europa en particular
el gran repunte de casos no es
únicamente debido a omicron es debido a
la variante del 30 plus que está
alcanzando grandes proporciones de
contagios alta incidencia y va sumando
más sin más a la presión hospitalaria
que se genera por ingresos y ese caso
omicron viene a rematar esto y es la
cereza en el pastel
señor lópez las farmacéuticas pfizer y
variante que anunciaron que la dosis de
refuerzo de su vacuna puede ofrecer una
protección significativa contra la
variante omicron serán suficientes los
refuerzos o se requerirá más vacunas
específicamente adaptadas
bueno no podemos únicamente estar
fundamentados en los anuncios de las
propias farmacéuticas se necesitan
llevar a cabo ensayos clínicos revisados
por padres publicados en revistas
científicas para determinar si esto es
en efecto el caso y hay una efectividad
de la vacuna ante la variante ahora lo
más importante es que determinemos
shiomi cronificada o no la eficacia de
las vacunas porque si se escapan habrá
que ir hacia las nuevas formulaciones de
vacunas en nuevos ciclos o menos señor
lópez que es lo que más preocupa a la
comunidad científica sobre esta variante
son efectivas las restricciones como las
que acaba de anunciar inglaterra
bueno implantará anunciar restricciones
seis meses después el error de
inglaterra fue no haber tomado estas
restricciones antes de omicron a la
estación no hay que tomar las broncas
hay que tomarlas por el avance de la
pandemia y esto es lo que no han sabido
hacer oportunamente en el caso del reyno
las restricciones que impiden los
contagios van a ser eficaces con omicron
o con cualquier otra variante pero es
todo lo únicamente pasa por la uar túnel
sino por las medidas de protección de la
mascarilla la distancia física de la
higiene y las medidas restrictivas que
impiden las interacciones sociales es
patético